the possession of Hannah grace has
finally reached cinemas unlike the
cadaver of the titular character there's
a lot to uncover from the film
throughout this video I'll be discussing
everything you need to know about the
movie as well as its ending there will
be heavy spoilers so those who want to
go into the film with fresh eyes should
turn off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to we follow Megan an ex-cop that
has started a new career as a morgue
assistant prior to joining the mortuary
Megan failed to use her firearm which
led to the death of her partner this is
sent her into an almost crippling
depression that she struggles to recover
from Megan has a pretty mundane life she
works the graveyard shift and is given a
little responsibility beyond the minor
tasks this all changes however when the
body of Hannah grace arrives Hannah is
evil incarnate and it's clear that
though her body is dead the spirit that
resides in her isn't Hannah's body seems
to be healing and this is because as she
kills she takes the life force from the
living and bestows it upon herself
we learned that Hannah was killed during
an exorcism by her father and that she
was buried
however she escaped from the graveyard
and began a killing spree Hannah's
father arrives at the morgue to inform
Megan of this and we discover that he
has been tracking the girls movements
and attempting to stop her before she
can do any more damage he states that
the only way to stop Hannah is by
burning her the two worked together to
take Hannah's body to the incinerator
but when Hannah burns her father alive
instead things look bad for the duo
Megan's boyfriend shows up to save her
but Hannah tries to murder him which
leads to Megan shooting her several
times with his gun this of course shows
a counterbalance to the mistakes she
made with her last partner and it's
clear that the character has now learned
to act in difficult situations
Megan manages to take the body to the
incinerator where she burns it Megan
seemingly continues her life as normal
after the events however when stepping
out of the shower we know is that one of
her eyes has turned blue much like
Hannah's
an ominous fly circles around Megan and
a clearly hints that the demon has
latched on to her it was able to do this
because of her depression which was
noted as a key trait of how it possessed
Hannah the blue eye is subtle enough to
pass a lot of viewers by but I
definitely think symbolizes that the
demon isn't dead so what are your
thoughts on the possession of Hannah
grace did you enjoy the film
and what's been your favorite horror of
2018 comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and check out my breakdown of
the mid-season finale of The Walking
Dead which will be linked at the end of
this video this is a channel for people
who are heavy into horror so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]